okay so our cultural thought leaders
have now embedded the coveted lifestyle
it's a lifestyle it's an actual
lifestyle but you're a good person if
you believe in the innate power of kovid
so you know those of us who are actually
religious we talk about two aspects of
of worship of god okay if you're a jew
there are two things particularly you
talk about when it comes to attitude
toward god there's jurassim which is
fear of god and then there is ah
right then there's love of god which
miami in this case being sort of a st
means heaven literally but we use it as
a stand-in for god's name
so there's fear of god and there's love
of god and as a religious person you're
supposed to have both you're supposed to
fear god's justice because if god ever
implemented his justice with you you
would surely be screwed and you're
supposed to love god because god has
given you all that you have and
constructed a universe that is that is
made for man right this is the basic
idea of fear of god and love of god well
the paganistic secularists when it comes
to coven they have fear of covet and
love of kobed they have a bizarre fear
of covet they believe that only by
by attempting sort of paganistic
sacrifices if they wear the mask and if
they dictate that you wear the mask if
they offer their children up on mount
moriah as sacrifices to covet mask up
the five-year-old and make sure that
this kid does not go to a bro this kid
cannot go to aladdin unless this kid is
double triple quadruple octuple baxt
then this will somehow
this will somehow prevent the wrath of
kovad right fear of covet and then
there's love of kobe these people love
it they love it covet has constructed an
alternative universe where they get to
do whatever they whatever they want
where they get to dictate all the terms
of engagement where people have been
more willing to give up power to
government than any time in american
history people are just willing to like
they're throwing power at government
especially in the blue states like okay
fine you want to ask us please mask us
please master mask us please do it
please throw just do it
please tell us what jobs we can and
cannot work please tell us whether we
can open our business whether we can to
open our business and if we fear kovid
and we love covet enough it will usher
in a new kingdom of covet glory upon
earth where we build back better where
we wreck all the institutions where we
get rid of logic where we get rid of
data and we live solely on faith we live
as one in faith with covid
that is the attitude and that's why you
end up with idiotic pieces of culture
like jimmy fallon cutting songs for
christmas with ariana grande and megan
the stallion
her middle name is the i'll never get
over this it's megan the stallion which
i assume was not her given name but
megan these not not the stallion which
would make some sense because then she
would be the stallion megan the stallion
you my friend are the stallion because
it's t-h-e-e megan the stallion with
ariana grande singing with jimmy fallon
who's uh who's aging like a bad piece of
cheese over here
um i gotta say i remember when jimmy
fallon was young and he is now reaching
the age where this is just kind of
creepy and
and odd and sort of yucky here he is
singing a song with ariana grande and
megan the stallion about masking up for
christmas and they're so here's the
thing they're playing it as parody but
they're actually kind of comfortable
with it they kind of love it they're
kind of into it because this means that
they are they are the elite they get to
dictate to you what sort of sacrifices
you should perform sure christmas is
supposed to be a time for christians
where you celebrate the birth of jesus
christ but for jimmy fallon and ariana
grande and megan lee stallion all of
whom
are definitely i would say excellent
advocates on behalf of traditional
christian worldview what christmas is
truly about
is um is coveted masks and shots
and uh sitting by the fire
wearing odd accoutrements
[Music]
uh her fingernails are syringes in case
you can't see
and now you have a person twerking while
wearing um
paper towels and they're spraying
everything with uh
with hand sanitizer
somebody wiped off snow
hey
i promise we'll be okay
[Music]
i
and then uh this creepy thing of jimmy
fallon wearing a mask with ariana
grande's face on it and uh the same
thing with her
[Music]
we'll be in line for a booster
here's the thing it's obviously look
he's trying to be funny and jimmy fallon
hasn't been funny for for quite a while
here but
it is um it is
pretty amazing
um
megan says this year hang that mistletoe
i'ma kiss everybody that i know
and um but it was a masked christmas we
stayed in the house we covered our nose
and covered our mouth but now that
boosters are available
then they can they can party it up
until they can't of course because
according to dr anthony thatcher by the
way even if you're fully boosted you
should still mask up when you are in the
presence of others
in fact there's an entire article in the
atlantic it is titled how to socialize
safely in the booster area in the
booster era okay so um i have a
recommendation ask you how to socialize
safety in the booster era get a booster
or don't and then do whatever the hell
you want cause it's a free country and
shut the f up there we're done wasn't
that amazing
incredible
because the vaccines are widely
available and we have therapeutics
and omicron is less threatening than
delta
and you're fine
shut up
stop like enough
but we still have to hear from our our
masters that the high priests have coped
and so the atlantic says this past
spring if someone told you they were
fully vaccinated you knew precisely what
they meant at least two weeks before
they'd received two doses of moderna two
doses of pfizer or one of johnson and
johnson now what it means to be
vaccinated encompasses much more variety
some people have gotten their initial
doses but haven't gotten a booster some
people mixed and matched the brands of
their first shots in their booster
what's more everyone is on their own
personal timeline depending on when they
got their shots amid this complexity
kids under 5 still aren't eligible for
any shots at all when trying to gauge
whether a gathering will be risky
the most important variable by far
continues to be whether the attendees
are vaccinated
jessica melania rivera a research fellow
at boston children's hospital told me
she wouldn't feel safe spending time
with an unvaxxed person indoors if she
saw them at all the meetup would be
outside and with masks outside and with
masks
but she's vast and probably boosted
like what
uh
it's so tiresome it's tiresome but again
all this makes them feel better about
themselves it makes them feel
self-righteous
just like all other virtue signaling
from the left it is all about doing
irrelevant things that have no impact on
the real world and then saying that your
friends aren't doing it so you're better
than they are
it's like composting or or recycling or
in a big city where they take all your
your recycling and they toss it into the
same landfill as your garbage they're
like oh well did you did you fully use
your recyclables okay guys i'm sorry
if you're building your notion of a
virtuous life around whether you are are
boosted and whether you're
[Music]
bottom line is this until our bodies are
at least 85 percent comprised of just
the vaccine
until our body weight is 80 vaccine
we can't go back to normal but here's
they never want to go back to normal
this is the new normal they love it they
love it
these people are not miserable they are
happy they're happy in their misery
because here's the thing if they didn't
want to live like this they wouldn't
have to
you know how i can tell that because
we're down here in florida and ain't
none of us been living like that down in
florida my family has been out and about
since we were vast
end of story enjoying life having a good
old time going to synagogue with
hundreds of people
and i know that a bunch of people in
blue states who are cringing right now
oh my god went to synagogue with
hundreds of people yeah you know how
many people died
big zero
you know why is everybody who want to
get facts not facts i don't know how
many times i have to say this leave
other people alone you're not a better
person for trying to control other
people's lives when they do not pose a
risk to you
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe